hey guys this is the Reuben report i'm
still the improvement I've got Lysette
padilla kim horror with me we have a
tremendous amount of paper on this desk
that means we know what we're talking
about so let's get right to it obviously
the big story this week is the prisoner
swap we got back sergeant Bowe Bergdahl
from Afghanistan in exchange for five
Taliban prisoners from Guantanamo Bay
there is all kinds of stuff going on
that by the time we post this will
probably change there's some questions
to whether six soldiers actually died
while looking for him he may have been a
deserter and had not been captured
actually all kinds of stuff but I wanted
to talk about this Jeffrey Toobin on CNN
he is their legal analyst I often don't
agree with him on a lot of stuff usually
about the NSA but he's saying that
President Obama actually broke the law
by not going to Congress before
authorizing the prisoner release let's
take a look you looked at the law you've
looked at the signing statement you've
gone through it did the president break
the law by engaging in this deal oh I
think he clearly wrote the law the law
says 30 days notice he didn't gave 30
days notice now it is true that he
issued a signing statement but signing
statements are not lost signing
statements are the president's opinion
about what the law should mean now it
may be that the law is unconstitutional
a violation of his pad powers commander
of chief but no court has held that the
law is on the books and he didn't follow
it okay so as far as i know we still
have something called the constitution
in this country even if we don't pay
that much attention to it so yes he had
this signing statement but that doesn't
supersede the law so that's what i want
to talk about here does anyone care
about the law line to say like are we
still surprised that obama broke the law
i mean what about ordering a drone
strike on an american citizen without
due process in secret what about the
unprecedented warren whistleblowers what
about spying on the American people with
the NSA are counting dead military-aged
males killed by drone strikes as
combatants or signing into law the
enshrining of the executive power to
indefinitely detain terror suspects
without trial really we're surprised
yeah so well done Kim you took care for
my bullet point there
sorry yeah no that was perfect that was
perfect that was my point that we've
done so much of this doesn't excuse it I
mean no sure we're not surprised but I
don't think it excuses it I mean I think
in this particular case does really
matter that Congress got approval and
probably not really because they would
probably agree with it anyway so in this
particular case I don't really think it
matters i think the bigger issue is that
this keeps happening and it's sad that
we're not surprised about it yeah so
President Obama did issue a statement
about this we have consulted with
Congress for quite some time about the
possibility that we might need to
execute a prisoner exchange in order to
recover sergeant Bergdahl we saw an
opportunity we were concerned about
sergeant Bergdahl's health we had the
cooperation of Qatar ease to execute an
exchange and we seize that opportunity
and the process was truncated because we
wanted to make sure that we did not miss
that window now what they are also
saying is that Bergdahl had some health
issues now he's being checked right now
but it's no one knows where he is
exactly so we haven't been able to
verify that that there was some sort of
health issue that made this you know
that they needed to have this happen
immediately so even that statement
though like I get it like he's like we
are we wanted to make this happen want
to make a quick it's sensitive but again
that doesn't supersede the law so should
anyone should we do anything about this
because I think this is the type of
thing that the media is just going to
drop and it's like I he broke the law
again Zippity doo-dah I think because it
made strategic sense we're not that
upset about it right but I think the
major issue is that they keep he keeps
breaking the law this administration the
format administration keeps breaking the
law and a lot of times it doesn't make
sense and we don't get an explanation so
I think though that if we had more trust
in the government and stuff like this
would be more passable I think I'm just
really upset because this is just
another example of how the law is not
followed and how we are not given
information at all I can you mentioned
so many things that all those things
y'all forgot about so all of those
things when you add up all those things
are those how do you think we're going
to look back at the Obama presidency
especially when it comes to these sort
of security issues and the spying and
all that like he really in my opinion at
least has severely dropped the ball here
well yeah but we're sort of used to him
dropping the ball but in this case I
feel like we know so little about
Bergdahl's you know was he deserter was
he sick how many people died looking for
him where is he now they're so there's
such a lack of transparency that I think
will will remember for a long time would
any of that change your opinion on this
if it turned out that he was really sick
and they knew he had two weeks to live
with that then mitigate you saying well
okay he can he can go ahead and break
laws we want him back before he dies
again I think in this particular
situation I'm not part I'm not upset
about the strategic yeah um you know
move that was taken and it broke the law
because laws are meant sort of has
safeguards they're meant to like guys I
those are meant to be broken yeah
they're meant to be broken because
sometimes they don't make sense um but
the issue is that these laws keep being
broken when we don't have any
information or any transparency as you
mentioned as to why it makes sense to
break the law yeah do you think the
mainstream media might be more upset
about this if it was say president bush
well you'll have to remember that
present their precious President Reagan
did a simple actually far worse created
weapons to Iran yeah and it was a huge
failure and we kind of forgot about that
isn't he the messiah of the republican
party now right and also people were
saying well we don't negotiate with
terrorists that's what that's what
everyone on the right on the
conservatives were all saying right now
except we've done it with the pattern
this was a negotiation this was a
prisoner swap which is different than
negotiating with terrorists it's on it
sort of a negotiation but it's not
exactly if they they're there yeah
that's all that's a whole other topic
let's move on to more pressing political
stuff a friend of george clooney's says
he might be jumping into the political
arena we've got a quote he has big
ambitions and aims to get into politics
eminently he wants to do more
humanitarian work in hopes to join the
Democrats 2016 election campaign George
is thinking of how he can get more
involved now he has a mild by his side
it will give him more credibility to run
for office of course uh this is a friend
of George Clooney's cloody obviously is
no stranger to politics uh he helped
Obama get reelected in 2012 he does a
lot of political fundraising he's been
involved in Darfur he's also married
british lawyer amal alamuddin and she
defended wikileaks Julian Assange and
she's a human rights specialist so
obviously he has interest that go
beyond just acting and the reason I
wanted to do this story because of
course this is just conjecture and it's
one friend that saying this but i'm a
firm believer that the way everything's
heading in this country we're going to
just start voting in celebrities I mean
Hillary is already becoming more of a
celebrity than a politician and Obama
was sort of a celebrity candidate and I
think that's the route this is going for
better or worse is this is this net bad
or net good this this celebrity
political mumbo jumbo it depends on the
celebrity but I think it's an issue when
we take someone celebrity status or for
example Arnold Schwarzenegger like macho
skills and you know power in movies and
transfer it over to the real world I
think that's the issue when we assume
that these characters that they play on
television are actually part of who they
are right so you wanted Schwarzenegger
like bust into the Capitol in Sacramento
with a gun no no I wanted him released
oh baby yeah but that's a different
story I just think that it's kind of
crazy how we all automatically attribute
sort of characteristics to celebrities
and assume that that's who they are I
think that's why people fall in love
with celebrities they don't realize that
they're actors right so that's the part
that I think is really interesting about
this because if you look at Cluny he
looks presidential right people people
like him he could play the president
very easily he played a presidential
candidate before where would it was
believed it was called The Ides of March
I did not see that one mrs. courtesy of
Ben mankiewicz from turner classic
movies would you vote for Clooney would
you vote for Hillary no because on one
hand like he seems like he's on the
right side of things he's pro-gay rights
he did a lot of work for Darfur before
anyone else did the other hand he might
be a little bit of an Obama crony like
what happens when his idealism gets kind
of crushed and he's surrounded by these
people that say you do this you do that
and he becomes a different man yeah well
you're saying is he's not strong enough
I mean you work out but what I found
really funny about that quote was it was
kind of intimating like oh now he's
ready now that he's about to have a wife
given these qualified right he's getting
this wife so suddenly if you have a wife
then obviously you can be you could be
present just to clarify were saying
earlier I don't think that the celebrity
thing
politics is like a net good in general
but I do think there's maybe like a
little room we're having people that are
already rich and already popular maybe
would be a little more honest because
they wouldn't be beholden to all the all
the corporate interests maybe maybe a
little bit I know it's a slippery slope
and even as I'm saying it it sounds kind
of gross east of see politicians who
started at celebrities and one were
conservative so the only two I can think
of our Al Franken and well maybe it
wasn't Ashley Judd was going to yeah so
she didn't maybe it's not the worst
thing in the world yeah do you guys
think we need what they have in most
European countries a president and a
prime minister so one the president that
sort of the celebrity that does all the
ceremonial stuff and then a prime
minister that actually does what are
present does like actually does the work
because I think that might help if we
were able to get some of the like
paparazzi stuff off with the President
and then have someone else that was
actually doing the work do you think
that would help I feel like that kind of
happens already i mean i don't assume
that president obama's they're actually
doing something you Oh Ziggy no I kid
but I'm I feel like they probably had he
probably has a certain set of
responsibilities our president does
right and then the others are divvied up
right but don't you think so much of it
is just going to the fundraiser showing
it but these events as opposed to doing
the work I think you agree with me right
yeah like absolutely yeah it's a lot for
one percent I just think that they
already kind of Divya give me it up what
do you think should we have a president
and a prime minister I'm sorry we're not
a monarchy oh yeah another thing you
know Bob oh wow oh it might be I don't
know about that I don't know about that
one Dave no no no all right my crazy
idea i want to turn us a little more
into europe all right i'm nuts okay
speaking of nuts google cars they are
coming they are gonna be self-driving
they're not even gonna have steering
wheels so when the car goes crazy you
won't even have a chance people let's
look at some specs from the upcoming
google car they're gonna have some
interesting safety measures like a
flexible windscreen foam like material
the maximum speed for now 25 miles per
hour so you're not taking a
cross-country trip on this thing they'll
be button first start
and pull over an emergency stop in case
I'm crazy happens of course sensor is
used for self-driving so that they know
that they're not going to hit another
one of these Google cars or a regular
car and seating for two passengers we've
also got a little videotape of what the
Google car is going to look like there's
no steering wheel in ok so starting in
2015 Google is going to start using
these cars in states that permit it for
states right now allow the testing of
self-driving cars on public roads
California Nevada Florida and Florida
and Michigan so I guess the first thing
is would you trust these vehicles this
seems kind of crazy you're putting a lot
of faith in the machine listen people
have brought up before you know what if
your car gets hacked what if someone
over rides your computers if even if you
have a steering wheel you're still
pretty [ __ ] in this way right I hate
to break it to you but yeah there's
there's a few things that aren't
accounted for here like what if you need
to wait for your you know grandma to get
out of the car in the car or what do you
if you need to go find parking in a
several stories tall parking structure
and it doesn't read it like you know as
being more than one story tall or there
there's so many little things and I feel
like aren't accounted for right
technologically just are kind of
concerned a little i mean not sick not
all situations can be i don't think it's
ready yet you know like what if i need
to park off road yeah I'd like we're
ready either yeah you don't think humans
are ready he was ready like I mean I
know they did like studies five to ten
years ago at Stanford where they had
driverless cars and people freaked out
granted it's been some time since then
but still people are really
uncomfortable not being in control
particularly of a moving object it's in
our nature to want to be in control of
our feet and where we move it makes no
sense to be in a car I think
biologically our instincts tell us
absolutely not right so before we fully
get to the hacking and all the evil
things that the machines are gonna do to
us I think that
an interesting part of this that just
giving up the control I mean just that
just getting into this thing and having
faith that it's not going to get hacked
into or just something crazy isn't going
to happen or someone else that's driving
because obviously we're not going to all
change over it want someone else that's
driving normally is gonna just smack
right into you anyway you know like
there's just a lot of pieces here this
is a good idea if all the cars are
automated because then you know traffic
would be cut down evidence would be cut
down but when you're still counting on
half the time like other people's
ability to not crash into you and kill
you it's not incredibly fortuitous there
are so many ethical concerns that like
involve having all automated cars too
though like for example you know there
could be a case where a crash is
inevitable if one car has three people
the other car has one person what should
the car do who should the carpet texture
to protect you as the like car owner or
should it couldn't communicate with the
other there are three people there save
those three lives and kill you like
there are also many questions what are
those laws called is there a phrase for
those laws that robots are going to have
to abide by like from iRobot like that
kind of thing where they're going to
have to say like oh there's three lives
in this car one just as you just said
and they're gonna have to make decisions
know the word I keep making prime
directive and I know that's not it yeah
cuz I just Star Trek I have other
concerns about these cars when I was
watching this video I kept thinking
about this how did that get in this taxi
the door open you dalian
you want to do it with that guy that
guy's freaky that's my point you're
gonna have these Johnny cabs and they're
gonna be freaking people out that's the
total recall of course one of my
favorite um yeah so it's open your
brother because that helps in the
studies they've shown that if they have
like a little tiny robot little tiny
robot in a driverless car people are
much more comfortable yes yes you do too
I would trust r2d2 to control my vehicle
I don't know that I want Jonica but that
even is interesting because we still
want some level of human interaction
there which is why when they when they
wrote that scene they had the guy looks
sort of like but it's scary that was far
worse than having none there yeah okay
so let's just let's finish up with the
with this machine's idea that and the
hacking and all that kind of thing I
mean if this stuff is inevitable then
shouldn't we be fighting it anymore
shouldn't we be fighting it more you
know I mean we're all walking around
with these devices that can be hacked
into we're all we're going to be in cars
that can be happier do all this stuff
and if you can already be hacked into
cars can be hacked into now with OnStar
and all that well now is the time to be
forming legislation or some kind of
figuring out how what what the order of
this is and how it should work and we
should understand how it all works so
that we're able to voice our opinions
effectively rather than just being like
oh okay yeah i'll check dart whoa you're
saying that our politicians should have
foresight into things that we know are
coming and they should take understand
it what you're saying that we as the
populace should understand something and
our politicians should have foresight to
deal with it I'm saying knowledge equals
good that's why you hos nerd alert those
crazy nerdy thoughts let's say you wanna
bring us home on this I was um I don't I
can be as nerdy but I was thinking about
car ownership and how this could
potentially change that how we may no
longer own cars if it becomes really
cheap to just have a driverless car come
pick us up and like take us we don't
have to worry about insurance or gas or
somebody driving it might make sense and
that kind of excites me because I feel
like it'll lead to lower carbon
emissions all right all right we brought
this around to not necessarily the car
apocalypse so I kind of feel good about
that all right let's talk about the NRA
and no I'm not talking about the
National Rifle Association I'm talking
about the NRA the National Restaurant
Association which might be slightly more
dangerous believe it or not uh this is a
political I be representing the nation's
largest food service companies and
they're one of the most powerful
lobbyists on Capitol Hill they get a lot
of crazy [ __ ] done let's take a look
okay so they have nearly fifty two
thousand members and this includes olive
garden McDonald's red lobster starbucks
things like that uh they have a PR firm
permanent company which is famous for
opposing sensible public interest and
safety laws uh their leaders are in
Fortune 500 companies and they have a
budget of 65 million dollars and they
employ 40 lobbies okay so on its face
nothing here sounds that bad this is
just how America works but so there's a
lot of information here so you can pause
it and read it on your own but some of
the things that they've done they've
defended pink slime in burgers which
we've talked a ton about inhumane
conditions for poultry they've opposed
industry pledges to raise pigs humanely
they've opposed Paycheck Fairness Act
for waiters and waitresses Pregnancy
Discrimination Act and they blocked a
federal minimum wage increase for
restaurant employees they found
loopholes to exclude employees from the
new health care law all kinds of stuff
and there's a lot more and I nobody
talks about this and you know we talk
about lobbying a money in politics all
the time here but I thought this was
sort of interesting because it brings it
literally to our table right the stuff
that we are putting in our body yeah
this stuff right there should we know
more about the National Restaurant
Association did you know about this
before we sent you guys the article way
uh in full disclosure I worked for Olive
Garden when I was in high school so you
really yeah I knew we were part of the
NRA the other day a different name
because we also associate NRA with
obviously the rifle thing or this is
their plan like hi like hiding in plain
sight right what wasn't it wasn't you
know the WWF used to be the World
Wrestling Federation and then the World
Wildlife Federation stepped in and then
the WWF the wrestling one became World
Wrestling Entertainment resign so
shouldn't we force this other an array
to get another name so we can all focus
on them a little understand
get a good look at them yeah sure yeah
wait before we move any further what do
we need to know about the unlimited
salad it's too good to be true right a
lot of calories in that thing you know
what's what you can what you know what
you can switch the salad and you can
switch the soup for free what do you
mean for what like could you get
unlimited soup salad and breadsticks you
can get like one type of salad and then
it's still unlimited if you want to
switch it to a Caesar if you want to go
with the minestrone and then the chili
yeah and then the Toscana even Neil whoa
you well you know when you're here are
the Reuben reporting your family so
there you go ok so yes so it shouldn't
surprise us I suppose that a lobbying
that are you know an association like
this would use lobbying to do all these
horrible things but shouldn't we know
about this shouldn't we be talking about
this wise has never discussed it's funny
because we talk about these stories like
Papa John's opposing Obamacare and
saying oh who crippled is but then
finding out it doesn't we think like oh
let's do it okay that guy's not cool but
then we learned there's this whole Lobby
espousing all these ideas across the
industry it's not just one one
billionaire yeah um should the
government why is the government so
involved in our food is isn't that like
the bigger problem here that we've so
separated ourselves from our food source
you know to me and we don't do any kind
of farm-to-table stuff so that of course
you're when you have all these middlemen
that are you know putting laws in that
allow for all these chemicals and all
this other stuff yeah that's a big
question why is the government involved
in her food it's necessary for survival
you know in the same way that it's
involved in our air and keeping it clean
to both of late um but it's also
involved in our food for profit because
it has a lot of corporate interests to
protect I mean look at the dairy
industry the subsidies that they get
agriculture it's a it's a place where
they can make a lot of money and
politicians get a lot of money from
these corporations so it matters them
yeah so money in politics of course one
of the things that I thought was
interesting is that they've fought
against lower sodium levels in food
which generally they say lower sodium is
Reese is good that's why they want to
sell more food and they want their
products to be tasty oh so you're saying
that the NRA is not in it for our public
good they're in it for us to buy more of
their [ __ ] I mean are they in it with
the salt people like you know to be like
is it just is it just one big
[ __ ] I'm sure if we look further
will find that there is profit to be had
in certain areas and that that's why
it's happening what drives me crazy is
that they were fighting to keep a tipped
server wages so low and two and fighting
the minimum wage increase yeah I mean in
other countries you know like for well
for the tipping thing yeah they're
they're kind of I don't encourage
tipping or its looked upon it as more
you know like oh you don't think I was
good enough in my job yeah it's more of
a blue something you can be pried
prideful of even your your work as a
waiter yeah well speaking of that do you
guys know that YouTube is gonna start
putting a tip jar right over there so
I'm just saying if you like what we're
doing here you could just it's not there
yet I don't think okay let's move on in
Sweden they are going to test out
something that is very unamerican they
want to see if working less will
actually increase productivity that's
right the city government of Gothenburg
Sweden it wants to test the impact of
shorter hours and how that affects
productivity in an experiment that
begins in about three weeks so one group
of government workers in the elderly
care sector are going to work six hours
a day while another are gonna work the
eight hours that their custom to working
after a year the government is going to
analyze the results and decide whether
the six hour day actually allows people
to accomplish just as much as they were
doing with two extra hours of course uh
proponents of cutting the work day are
saying that you know people have fewer
sick sick days and they'll be more
efficient in general and the
International productivity ranking by
conference board a non-profit business
research organization Sweden was already
close to the top coming out 11th in 61
countries in terms of productivity and
we've got some more info on that for you
so this is average work hours and
international productivity rankings okay
so what you can see here is that in the
Netherland they don't work a ton but
they're ranked fifth in productivity
pretty good you
it's AIT's we do work a lot an average
of roughly 400 more hours a year than
they do in the Netherlands and we are
productivity is pretty good
interestingly in Chile and in Mexico
they work a ton and their productivity
is not good so there's all sort of it's
a little all over the place but also I
think you can get some interesting stuff
from this so let's just start with the
the American component since we're in
America here this is very unamerican
right to say oh you should work less and
maybe that'll make me more but up
because we're just taught to work and
work and work till we drop I'm not
working hard it's working smart so if
you're if you're tired and you're hating
life yeah you're gonna work much more
poorly so I kind of see think Sweden has
a point here yeah should we jump on this
bandwagon that Sweden because I think
when they do that once they get the
information back on this they're gonna
see ya people can work more nimbly and
more swiftly I think it's it would be a
great thing if people worked for your
hours because we work a ton a lot of
like people are independent contractors
nowadays as well and they're working
more than 40 50 60 hours we have a lot
of young lawyers that are going crazy
100 120 hour work weeks I think that's
unacceptable but I think that if we are
going to lower the minimum number of
hours for full time work from say eight
to six we also have to make some changes
so that workers are engaged and we're
getting the same level of productivity
we know that certain activities at work
lead to you know lead to results and
others don't so that's where we should
focus our energy making people happier
more engaged at work so let's talk about
happiness because we never talk about
that right that's the that's the one
thing that's never talked about uh is
the relation between work and happiness
so they've done studies that show that
people that are working are generally
happier because then you have money and
you can go do things and take vacations
and things like that but we don't really
talk about it on sort of a day-to-day
basis like where happiness is coming
from and people i'm sure that are
working 100 hour work weeks probably not
that happy right no you miss your family
you're not sleeping enough you're not
eating enough you're not seeing your
friends you're not getting the things
done that you need to get done that
aren't even fun at all yeah of course
you're stressed out do you guys think
that as the economy changes and now that
we can do everything online and
computers and things like that that you
could accomplish as much in three hours
as maybe they used to be able to
accomplish all day long so the
so I feel like a lot of people right now
people that are watching there are a lot
of people watching this at work we know
a lot of the a lot of our videos are
watched during work hours and people are
at work without things to do actually
because it's sort of the old paradigm of
like working nine to five but actually
you can accomplish all you needed to do
from like nine to eleven this idea of
working to like from nine to five comes
from like the the times of Agriculture
when we had to wake up at a certain time
and then there was light and so we used
us all the valuable light time and then
we went to bed after the sunset or
whatever so it makes no sense to apply
to like today's society where we have
artificial light where we have the
internet where we can communicate
globally I think that what's happening
though is that because we have all these
technological advances we just want
people to do more and their bosses
expect more out of us like now like you
know I've so many of my friends tell me
my boss sends me an email at three
o'clock in the morning and I'm expected
to respond like that's [ __ ] nuts what
is it good isn't it you get emails at
that hour don't you feel that because I
see it all the time i get emails i wake
up my check later to the morning like 10
I would getting was like 10 or on the
weekends and get me expected to respond
to that I'm like [ __ ] this like this is
not okay yeah so is that the huge
drawback to the technology because now
they're saying how how people don't even
stop working when they're on vacation
now because everyone has an iphone and
you can literally yeah on the beach
you're like oh [ __ ] you know that yes I
know people like from worker like I ha
put out this fire it's like I'm in a
different state now no but yeah I can
definitely see this I feel like most of
the work day is spent you know hurry up
and wait or wasting time running out the
clock and it doesn't need to be that way
we can enjoy our lives shockingly enough
and we can enjoy our work also
shockingly enough yeah so if Sweden
which already as we said they don't work
as much as us and they are more
productive if they find this to be true
and really push this idea all over the
country do you think they're gonna have
an immigration problem I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure they don't have the
easiest immigration policies in the
first place but really do you think this
is the place people would be like you
know what they're doing something right
there different though to their very
much focused on education much more than
you know the u.s. is and they're also
healthier they have a better
educational system they have a better
health system so I think those two
things also highly contribute to their
productivity it's not just about the
hours the fact that they have a society
where even if they're working for your
hours they're still working great there
you go all right one more for you let's
talk about condoms everybody loves
condoms right there is some new condom
technology that's right the Galactic cap
which claims to be stronger and safer
than traditional condoms and enable
better sensitivity we've got an image of
the cap okay so what's happening here
should we put a parental warning on this
video or graphic a no that's a that's
very horrific traffic sorry guys sorry
ladies alright so this but it's
basically like a tiny little cap that
goes on the top of the penis the rest of
the penis is exposed so you're gonna get
more sensitivity everyone in the studio
is really getting a kick out of this
thing one of the parts where its most
sensitive though look I don't tip love
the gym now the tip of the tip yeah
isn't that like really central generally
a little lower than the tip of the tip
you know you mean below the tip okay
good talk that's it for us uh no not
just the tip yeah ok so the condom it
compromises two parts a u-shaped
polyurethane adhesive film that wraps
around the penis that's what you saw
there sort of like a plastic around a
finger and a cap that sticks to firmly
trap the semen so a guy basically could
wear this all the time and be ready for
sex at any time do you think men would
ever women have to be on birth control
you know I mean women have to have taken
responsibility for their reproductive
healthcare sexual health men it doesn't
seem to me who would be able I'm going
to wear it for a long time and it's
going to get oh okay it might happen
yeah okay here's the thing that's gonna
happen people are gonna get AIDS and
they're gonna get gonorrhea herpes
because this only protects against
pregnancy it doesn't protect against any
STD so right well I guess there's some
question whether it'll protect against
some of the STDs because if it does trap
the semen it does trap the semen so the
skin on skin stuff I could still be so
there's some questions related to that
but just to be a little clearer about
how this thing actually works so you
could literally be wearing it all the
time and then when you want to have sex
if you can find someone that's willing
to do it with you uh you peel off the
paper backing on the cap and stick it to
the polyurethane to secure the bond
between uh the two but between the two
you know because the penis is an organ
well known for always having the right
amount of friction and always being dry
I'm sorry yeah I love that they
emphasize that you can wear it all the
time anytime I think it's crazy to think
that a woman will be like oh you know
for the first time you know getting you
know heavy petting or whatever and then
all of a sudden like a petting you don't
hear that one to us hey baby backing up
at Lookout Hill I mean the pants are
down and then you see it in your like
your milk oh [ __ ] and also i'm thinking
like you premeditated this did she use
it with somebody else before me like no
uh not happening you're not getting laid
if you wear that right and okay so okay
so for you guys if you were on a date
with a guy and then you know you got
back to to his place to your place where
we are and then you got naked and he
already had one of those on not
happening you'd be like what the fall
yeah you need to go get a new one at
least yeah we good yeah I like how you
really hung up on that I know what's I
don't like guys don't like to you need
to go the dark diligent about
cleanliness yeah we're around some dirty
no you need to go to fill an STD test if
you're gonna be wearing that it's not
yeah all right well I guess I don't have
to ask you my final question which was
do you think this condom will finally
revolutionize safe sex it sounds like
that's not going to be maybe in like
really committed long-term relationships
or whatever we're like say the pill is
giving like the girl an allergic
reaction or morning sickness like pills
are [ __ ] awful so if this is an
alternative to using the pill and the
like committed monogamous relationship
sure yeah but going back to what I said
earlier for guys it's just seems like
guys just aren't responsible another
would you even would you even trust the
guy if there was something that was
really like that small I mean would you
trust him
to you know to me like you turn your
head for a sec for all you know he rip
that thing off and you may not even know
as if I want to do that why would he
want to get me pregnant well he just may
want more since a selfish being so I
think yeah with [ __ ] I like you how
you have so much faith in men that's Kim
no faith in men with set a lot of faith
in men on that note do you have faith in
us let us know in the comments down
below click like subscribe all that good
stuff you can catch the set on the lip
TV which is also on the YouTube and Kim
is on nerd alert which is part of the
tyt network I hope you guys do that
already at this point and barring an
electrical outage people do this again
next week yeah